i want to return all of our rights i  want to go back to the kitchen  you see i hate driving let's give it  back  pearl needs a driver if anybody is a  driver out there  around anyone  anyone want to let me i don't really  like cleaning though i'll be a poor  housewife  a poor housewife like a bad one  she'll do the bare minimum if you're  looking for a bare minimum housewife you  know what they didn't think about  everything's automated nowadays if we  just stuck it out now we're back then  they had to hand wash the lawn yeah i  would have been horrible i'd have been  like no i'm not doing this you know what  i'm saying though like if we just waited  another 50 years everything would have  been automated house what so much easier  yeah housewives would have been gucci i  probably would not be in school if  if they didn't have women's rights i'd  probably be at home with what are we  doing